[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and this will be a
review for chapter 102 of attack on
Titan and just wow what like so much
happened in this chapter I can't even I
have no idea where to begin despite how
good the previous chapters were this is
easily the best chapter yet the attack
on Titan manga just keeps getting better
and better at this point in this chapter
we witnessed the return of maybe the
most iconic character in attack on Titan
spoiler alert it was Connie also so many
things happen there is so much to talk
about
it's just insane I can't wait to get
into it as always if you enjoy these
reviews and attack on Titan content in
general be sure to leave a like to let
me know if you are new don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you can be notified every time a new
video is up and by the way if you're an
artist that makes high quality fan art
for attack on Titan like drawings of the
Warhammer Titan for example please
contact me if you'd like to have your
work featured in one of our videos if I
can use your fan art for a thumbnail or
in a video I will credit you in the
description and link to your social
media so if that's something you're
interested in you can tweet me at anime
uproar or you can contact me on
Instagram also at anime uproar and now
let's get into it we start off with the
male military scrambling to deal with
the attack in Lee Barry oh and they are
calling back reinforcements but it seems
like these reinforcements will take some
time to arrive even the name of this
chapter is it's too late so in that
sense it doesn't necessarily look good
for the Marlon military as the military
is trying to deal with the survey Corps
in Liberia they are being outclassed and
outmatched by our boys and girls from
the island the survey corps is zipping
around the air with the 3d maneuvering
Gear shooting and dropping bombs and the
male soldiers are not used to dealing
with this type of soldiers so they are
getting absolutely wrecked we see gene
or Jean at this point with longer hair
he is urging the other members of the
survey corps to make sure that they
avoid civilian casualties as much as
possible which again emphasizes that the
survey Corps are not bad people they're
just doing what they feel like they have
to do to survive
Jean has a brief exchange with flock
where flock reminds John that these are
the people who have been attacking and
slaughtering innocent civilians on the
island meaning you know don't be too
sentimental about them we came here to
do what we have to do this leads into a
really powerful conversation between
Mikasa and Aaron back in the plaza
Mieke sub with tears in her eyes says to
Annan do you understand what you've done
you've killed innocent people including
children that is already irredeemable so
this clearly implies that Mikasa either
wasn't fully aware of Aaron's plan or
she didn't agree with it but decided to
go along with it anyway yet again all of
this stresses the terrible nature of war
of course the LD ins on the island are
the victims here they were attacked
first they were attacked by Marly even
though they were just living behind the
walls and minding their own business
thousands of innocent civilians on the
island were brutally murdered but here's
the problem there are innocent civilians
in Marlay as well and that sucks because
Aaron and the others have no choice but
to attack clearly Marly is planning to
attack the island again and kill them
all they are relentless and they will
not stop until they are stopped by force
so I understand why the survey Corps is
doing what they're doing they have no
choice but it still sucks that innocent
civilians on the male side and also
children like you don't Sofia have to
suffer because of the decisions of other
people and by this I mean the male
government and military but that is also
how things unfortunately work in real
life
in the real world in every war there are
innocent people and children on all
sides and it is often these people who
are defenseless that end up suffering
the most not the politicians who have
bodyguards and bunkers and so on attack
on titan is so good at reminding us of
the ugly nature of war in the real world
as Mikasa and Aaron are talking we
realize
that despite having its nape destroyed
the Warhammer Titan is still alive the
Warhammer Titan uses its hardening
ability to create a crossbow and it
launches a powerful projectile but
Mikasa quickly takes Aaron out of harm's
way
this confirms that the Warhammer Titan
can use its hardening ability to make a
variety of different weapons not just a
hammer and Annan is determined to eat
the Warhammer Titan in take its power we
also see that gabby is terribly upset at
the death of Sophia and Fudo and she
tries to get to the front lines of the
battlefield she comes face to face with
Sasha who is shooting male soldiers from
a rooftop their eyes meet and this is
again such a powerful moment because
look at how similar Sasha and Gabi look
especially their eyes these girls are
both members of the same LDN nation the
same people they are both human beings
and yet they are forced to fight each
other of course
Sasha doesn't kill Gabi because she
doesn't want to kill a child and then we
see Connie urging Sasha to move Connie's
hair is now longer which is cool I don't
have too much more to say about him but
Sasha guys
Sasha looks absolutely beautiful after
this time-skip despite the fact that we
see her in the middle of a fight does
anyone else think that Sasha is even
prettier now after the time-skip I don't
know about you but at this point I would
give her as many potatoes as she wants
the survey corps appears to have a
strategy that includes installing lights
on rooftops but we're not exactly sure
what they're up to the Warhammer Titan
appears in vulnerable to attacks against
ahead and MAPE which makes Eren realize
that the Warhammer Titans body was built
up from its feet not from its name and
then we learned something completely
insane I did not see this coming
the body of the shifter inside the
Warhammer Titan is not inside the Titan
at all instead the body of Willy Tiber
sister is in a crystal just like Annie's
the body is located beneath the plaza
and connected by some sort of umbilical
cord to the Titans foot how freaking
crazy is that
Eren grabs the crystal and rips the cord
connecting it to the Titan which makes
the Titan body collapse Aaron is about
to eat the entire crystal but at that
moment he is attacked by the jaw Titan
from behind Porco Galliard is about to
eat Aaron and take the founding Titan
power until his jaw is suddenly slashed
to the point that he can't even chew
through Aaron's name and who did the
slashing the one the only
captain mother Levi boys so much hype in
this moment I am in full fanboy mode I
don't want to be one of those reaction
channels where they're freaking out and
overreacting but this was epic
Levi is just a greatest porco begins to
retreat and he can't believe that in his
Titan form humans can pose a challenge
to him and take him down but this is
because the survey Corps has been
fighting Titans all the time that's
exactly what they trained for whereas
the people in Marlay only fight against
regular soldiers Porco calls the survey
Corps the demons of parodies and at this
point I am pretty freakin sick of
hearing that demons and Devils crap like
I realized that these people in Marlay
are brainwashed but seriously man as
much as we've gotten to sympathize for
the LD ends in Marlay in the last
several chapters at the end of the day
and after this chapter especially I know
that no matter what I am 100% on the
side of Aaron Levi and the audience from
the island I am sick of this disgusting
propaganda about LD ins being Devils I
am sick of the LD ins from RA hating
their own people and being so gullible
and believing this Marlay [ __ ] the
LD ins from the island were attacked
first the world wants to commit genocide
against them and exterminate them of
course they're going to fight back
they're fighting for their survival and
I am 100% behind them these LD ins in
Marlay need to wake up already
unfortunately at this point peek shows
up in her armored car Titan and starts
shooting down members of the survey
Corps
Aaron is distracted for an instant and
Willie's sister uses that opportunity to
create another Warhammer Titan body
while she is still inside the crystal
this confirms that she is still aware
and conscious while in the crystal which
means that any
is also aware and conscious inside her
crystal and this makes me think what is
going to happen with Annie is the fact
that the crystal has appeared again a
hint that Annie will be coming back
sometime soon
is this foreshadowing the chapter ends
as the Beast Titan approaches Zeke says
don't let them escape annihilate them
all as the cart jaws and Beast Titan
face-off against Aaron and the survey
Corps Gabi is also running towards the
battle for some reason with a gun
talking about killing Aaron I don't know
what she plans to do but we are in for a
rematch between Levi and the Beast Titan
we are in for an epic fight and don't
forget we haven't even seen Armin the
colossal Titan yet is he there somewhere
just waiting for the right moment to
strike also are those lights that they
were setting up related to Armin are
they supposed to signal where he is to
land and use the colossal Titans power
to explode and create a massive
explosion since we know that the survey
Corps is trying to avoid mass civilian
casualties this might suggest that no
Armin is not planning to explode but
what if the survey corps is planning to
lure all the male shifters in one
specific area marked by those lights and
then the colossal titan is going to land
there and explode and wipe out all of
the shifters and what about Zeke he says
he wants to annihilate the survey corps
in this chapter or it seems that way
which implies that he isn't on air
inside but and I say but someone on the
inside has to be working with Aaron
because don't forget that Porco and peak
were deliberately trapped before the
battle by someone who didn't want to
kill them but he wanted them out of the
picture Reiner is probably also trapped
right now beneath the stage after Zeke
more or less told him to go with Falco
to see Erik we know that Zeke has been
doing things behind the scenes like
secretly listening in on conversations
and just acting very sneaky overall how
crazy would it be if Zeke was actually
talking about the Marlin soldiers when
he said don't let them escape annihilate
them all but we just think that he was
talking about the survey
man I cannot wait to find out what
happens next let me know what you guys
think is Zeke on male side on Aaron's
side or on his own side also do you
think that this chapter just
foreshadowed Annie's return by showing
the same type of crystal and lastly
where does the colossal Titan come in in
all of this let me know down in the
comments and just on a side note how
crazy is the Warhammer Titan and its
power and that's it for this video guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed these types of videos be sure to
leave a like to let me know if you're
new don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell and we are now
posting daily anime content on Twitter
and Instagram if you happen to be on
Twitter or Instagram feel free to follow
us at anime uproar a brand new attack on
Titan video will be dropping on this
channel within a few days so please stay
tuned I now have to go and calm down
after this epic insane chapter but until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]